Maybe we can go
to the Snow Ball together.
Snow Ball?
It's this cheesy
school dance
where you go to the gym and
dance to music.
I've never been,
but I know you shouldn't go
with your sister.
-No?
-I mean…
You can,
but it'd be really weird.
You go to school dances
with…
some that, you know…
Someone that you like.
-A friend?
-Not a friend.
A…
A… Someone like a…
Hey.
Sky?
I'm a fixer because…
I have to be.
Because I'm supposed to be.
Because…
When I fix other people,
I don't have to think about
how fucking broken I am.
Sky…
We're all broken, Bloom.
There's a charm in that,
too.
It's sucks
you're avoiding me.
I put myself out there
and I was honest with you
and for that
I get the silent treatment?
Even if
you don't feel the same,
you can at least
be there for me as a friend.
You're making me feel crazy!
Honestly,
if I knew
that you were going to be
all weird
and that this was going to
jeopardise our friendship,
I never in a million years
would have told you
how I felt.
Because
it is becoming
incredibly clear that
you don't feel the same way.
Come back to the party.
Stop walking!
-Stop following me.
-It is not safe out here.
I forbid you
to go any further.
You cannot tell me
what to do.
Daphne.
You won't listen!
My most sincere apologies.
I…
And I know weird stuff
might be a trigger for you.
Thanks for telling me, Roz.
And, yeah. Weird stuff is
a trigger for me.
But…
honesty's…
kind of the thing
I value most these days.
So we're good?
We will be.
As soon as…
What?
Was that…
like your vision?
Usually my visions lead to
something bad happening.
This time…
Nothing bad happened,
Rosalind.
Hi.
Was I drooling?
Sorry.
How did it go? Did you
make it down there in time?
Yeah.
You stayed.
I just wanted to make sure…
you were ok.
Because the doctor
wanted to see
how my lung was healing
and he found a tumour
the size of a walnut
inside my left breast.
What?
And I don't have long.
-We will find someone.
-We…
-We'll find a doctor.
-No.
-You have to stop.
-Listen to me!
You have to stop!
There is nothing
that anyone can do.
Ok.
I'm going to find someone.
A doctor.
We have all the money
in the world.
We will go to the ends
of the Earth if we have to.
I love you. Do you hear me?
I will not lose you.
Mildred…
-I love you.
Sorry! Sorry.
Sorry.
Ok. Thank you.
Oh my God.
Sorry, I know that you were…
probably expecting Olivia,
we don't have to do anything
if you don't want to.
Truth be told, I've never
kissed anyone before.
I've wanted to.
Don't get me wrong.
For example,
I punched Ron Getler
in the sixth grade during
seven minutes in Heaven.
Sophomore year spring fling,
I was dancing
with Randy Melrose.
You know,
a romantic song came on
and I was like:
"What's going to happen?"
Until it just didn't,
because--
This isn't so bad!
Not so bad at all.
Wait!
I'm not…
I'm not… Hey, wait!
I'm not… Sorry, I'm not…
You could move in here
if you want.
You know? For free.
Really?
Yeah.
Really.
Sorry, I…
No, no.
I just wasn't ready.
I'm ready now.
Now or never.